القمامه حتى الان المتكدسه او كميتها هي
تجاوزت اليوم عشره الاف طن بحسب اخر
التحديثات التي نشرتها بلديه باريس هذه
القمامه متكدسه في الشوارع بسبب اضراب
عمال جمع القمامه لانهم جزء من هذا التحرك
الاحتجازي الاحتجاجي عفوا على رفع سن
التقاعد الى 64 عاما طبعا هذا الاضراب
الذي ينفذونه سيستمر حتى يوم الاثنين
المقبل والصعوبه اليوم هناك ان
القمامه التي منتشره الان وقام المتظاهرون
بحرقها كما ترون ونشرها في الشوارع اكثر
مما هي منتشره باتت تشكل خطرا على السلامه
المروريه وايضا السؤال الان من سيقوم
بازاله هذه الاكوان من الشوارع بعدما
القيت في منتصف الشوارع واصبحت تعيق حركه
المرور بشكل كبير الاضراب مستمر كما ذكرت
حتى يوم الاثنين المقبل وربما ايضا
يمددونه اكثر بعد اقرار قانون رفع سن
التقاعد اليوم من دون تصويت البرلمان
وهناك مذكرات حجب سوف تطرح في البرلمان من
قبل قوه اقصى اليمين زعيمه اقصى اليمين
مارين لو كان اعلنت انها سوف تقوم بطرح
مذكره لحجب الثقه عن الحكومه وكذلك ايضا
قوى اليسار مجتمعه هناك خمسه احزاب يساريه
تشكل تحالفا في البرلمان اعلنت انها ايضا
ستقوم من جهتها بطرح مذكره لحجب الثقه عن
الحكومه في البرلمان الفرنسي